hi I'm Francisco Rodriguez and I'm going
to talk about Wolfram Alpha in Spanish
that's going to be the next one alpha
localization release
hi I'm Francisco Rodriguez I work for
the wharf uh were from research South
America office and today I will talk
about work from NASA in Spanish or as we
will say in the theatre world for
another thing espanol
so this talk will be in English don't
worry I wanted to give it in Spanish but
I think most people she doesn't speak
Spanish so that's fine so a summary I
will talk about this next project of
Wolfram Alpha
we are ready released were from Haifa
Japanese and the next project that we
expect to release is what France final
Spanish so I will talk about a bit about
the project in general and some
challenge we have and what's coming we
are going to follow today so well I
guess you all know what's Wolfram Alpha
it's a very unique system we answer
questions anything you want to know we
try to answer it's being already in the
market for a bit more than 10 years you
already know there the address and we
want to do everything computable so all
the knowledge we know about everything
to be computable and to be accessible
with Wolfram Alpha it has some unique
features like for example this natural
language query you can ask natural
language we have trillions of data
points
millions of entities of data created
computer data some of the problems may
be here is that most of the sources we
have are also for the u.s. that's
something we also want to expand of
course and something very interesting is
that it has a dynamic presentation of
the results so it computes the results
on the fly so it tries to figure out
what you are asking and try
to compute something about that so it
generates the result in that moment
usually and that means that also we need
to have a way to generate them and the
problem is that another problem but one
feature is that usually we assume an
english-speaking way to generate the
things the sentences the results to show
them so that's something part of this
challenge of localizing worn out from so
what's the main motivation of doing this
localization is that initially water not
only what's written in English but
English is not the most spoken language
in there in the world but there are many
other languages with more than half
fifty million speakers so we have
Chinese languages we have Hindi Spanish
Russian Portuguese Indonesian etcetera
there are many languages so initially we
release it at it only in English then we
went to to Japanese the next step
probably is going to be Spanish Korean
which is also in very good shape and
then we want to expand to French -
Chinese - Russian probably then we will
like to expand even more but these are
the ones that are currently in progress
so now the wall we have is to make this
computational knowledge accessible not
only to English speakers but to
everybody internationally so we can say
anyone in I know
in Chile I can take and understand the
results with we have anyone in France
anyone in Russia etc so that's idea of
localizing to be able to reach everybody
anyway this project is built upon the
over the English version so this means
that
in the localized versions also an
English query will work because we are
building on top of the English version
and of course this localization effort
is done by a lot of developers
translators testers creators so we have
a huge team behind all this project and
something important is that we have
native speakers for every language so
that's something I think remarkable is
not that we are simply doing a Google
translation of everything but we have
people who actually was born in the
language so I can understand not only
the language but also the culture
because it's not only a matter of saying
okay one plus one is you know mizuna but
also maybe in some part it said in a
different way a different way to show to
display the scenes is important so a bit
about the status we already released
Wolfram Alpha Japanese so this product
was released last year it's being in
production for for a while now a bit
more than a year
the next expected release as I said is
from alpha Spanish but we can also show
how much is ongoing the the progress so
right now we are focusing only in the
math content and that's something
important too to set the the scope of
the period is that we are translating
the math content of Wolfram Alpha as
first release milestone because that's
actually the most used feature in alpha
so I think 90% of the queries are for
math content and in terms of how much we
have progress translating the whole side
if we take out all the entities because
the entities are millions of entities so
we have not translated them yet
Japanese surround 40% of output
correctly translated displaying
correctly Spanish is almost in 50 but in
terms of input it means in terms of what
you can input what you can ask about
Japanese is around 50% of all the
grammar rules that's what we call them
grammar rules in in alpha has been
translated to adapt it to Japanese of
course we don't need to translate
everything because - to translate for
example mathematical expressions in
general you need to translate exactly
all the symbols the symbol plus is the
same all the languages but sometimes we
also need some extra symbols for other
languages so in that sense I think we
are doing a good progressing in all the
languages Chinese also what is in very
good shape so of course that takes out
all the entities which is a different
product that we need to tackle also -
how to get the translation of all the
millions of entities we have in Alpha in
a proper way of course some common let's
say domains are translated like for
example I don't know names of the
countries that's a small set that we
already translated to all the languages
but but anyway we we are clear that the
first step is to translate all the math
content so what I was already talking
about this challenge which is all this
data that we need to translate all these
tokens all these grammar rules names etc
and the problem not the problem part of
this challenge is to translate did this
in all the components that are needed in
alpha so whorfin alpha it's a large
system has a component to interpret the
input as a different component to
display the input the calculus can be
coded
as a different component for storing the
data all these putlitz internally we
have there is a different component
which is the website itself so it has to
be also translated to be working on so
we need to work in many many places to
have a complete product and of course
how we compute dynamically the answers
is something that we need to consider in
each language by itself so for example
about sentence building so we need to to
build a sentence and usually in English
we put the words together and usually it
works fine but in other language we need
to be more careful there
you need to agree between the gender for
example of the subject verb the verbal
phrase etc you need to agree me too in
the adjectives and the nouns you need to
agree between different parts also when
you use a definite article or indefinite
article may be different in different
languages so that's something to
consider when building the sentences
numbers also will come with a unit for
example or with a noun
may have a different way to display for
sampling in Asian languages you need
this counter word in Russian you need to
inflect the world depending on the
number value so if it's 5 it's a
different value for meters than if it
were 4 so 4 for English is basically
singular and plural for other languages
may be more complicated all this logic
has to be incorporated into alpha and
it's been already working that way but
so it's part of the challenge we
encounter when we say said ok let's
translate all alpha so it was not as
easy as saying okay now instead of
saying more I will say mass in Spanish
so that's maybe one word but when you
have to build a whole sentence it
work so we need to refactor a lot of
code we need to implement a lot of new
auxiliary functions to handle the
inflections and how to build the
sentences we have added our own template
system to actually have a better way to
to display the sentences and that means
refactoring a lot of code and that's
still on progress of course so we have
focus on all the math stuff we still
need to expand to other domains of
course but that's a work in progress
other small challenge I'm talking for
example the decimal separator you know
that the decimal separator is the point
usually in English but in other
languages it may be the common in this
most European languages use the comma
only English in Europe but also the rest
of the world uses points so it's I've
have in Spanish in particular is
complicated because even when the comma
was the traditional decimal separator
now countries like Mexico which is
together with murdering us is using the
point actually so it's a it's a mix so
in in Spanish in US and Spanish in
Mexico they usually use the point in the
rest of Latin America it's like a mix I
have even seen newspapers articles in
Peru where they mix the usage of the
comma as decimal separator and as
thousands separator that's a mess so so
they have something like 1 comma 5 %
percent of 12 comma 0 0 0 to say 12,000
so in one line they mix the usage of the
coma even so that's a horrible mix we
have a steering in Spanish that we have
to also try to figure out from the user
input what they mean and that's hard to
tell sometimes
we've been progressing on that a lot but
it's anyway something
very challenging add the input input
heuristics and also we have to adapt to
different formats for this plane for
example about the date and time and the
date at an time it's in particular
interesting because it's not only a
matter of the language but also a matter
of the location so if I am speaking
Spanish in u.s. it's not more common to
talk in let's say 12 hours format or you
find Spain in 24 hours if I am Peru it's
a mixed within 24 hours and 12 format in
Colombia at 12 hours format etc so
depending on the place you have a
different format of the time of the date
that also applies for for English and
that's something we have really adapted
to spoken Saltz still not therefore for
the web results but that's part of the
same effort of having the right
localization for everybody also about
numbers it's interesting that we needed
to adapt how we split the numbers
because nothing all the languages they
split the numbers by blocks of 3ds and
and that's something that was
interesting to find I didn't know that
by the way before starting all this
problem the fact that in some Asian
language they split by blocks of 48 and
also something that is sometimes
confusing in particular for for
translating English and Spanish
is that the word billion which is this
very similar to be young it's actually
in a different scale because Spanish
French whole European that we still use
the long scale instead of the shorter
scale that now uses a u.s. English like
that means that 1 billion is 2 to the 9
but in Spanish whom be young it's
actually 2 to the 12 even when the word
is almost the same
and for French it's even worse because
of the world is highly the same spelling
the so for example if we ask for the
Spanish is paying population well in
English we will say about forty six
point four million people in Japanese we
will use a different figure to to see
that number in a block of four digits
and in Spanish we will generally use the
common proximal maintain when they say
comma quarter me on another challenge we
had was about the words that were only a
composed of one letter so that was a
problem because it's confusing also with
for example variables in Spanish the AE
or Y are also words with its own meaning
so what happens when we find them in
math expressions are they the word or
are they the preposition or the
conjunction or the the word Amin so we
try to figure out we try to we have done
a lot of work also trying to have a good
heuristic on how to interpret them we
have been successful nothing all the
cases but almost I think in many cases
where could be ambiguous and that's
where there isn't then I will show some
some examples for example for for this
case result where a kiss mass Agreda he
wore a dress e a kiss - here era
he wallah so that why here in the middle
is actually day and so I want to solve
two different equations and that's
working so it interprets correctly this
is two equation that I want to solve but
if I want to ask for the solution wound
equation where this a is a preposition
in this case the a is not actually
filling out its a preposition and if I
use a different preposition it works so
we're still progressing on how to
interpret all these equations and how to
separate when the hour
this part of the equation and when it's
part of the sentence yeah
the idea is that eventually which we
have the assumptions but have the best
guess to be the first default that does
the the proper idea but sometimes is
actually hard to have the world of
assumptions with this guessing of the
prepositions because the way Alfa
interprets the sentences that would be
the ideal case yes
before going to the examples some
something about the fact that Spanish is
spoken officially in 17 countries is the
fat tone in different levels in six
different countries in particular I show
here in Mexico where there are some
parts where is the de facto language
chosen and also Philippines and United
States are members of the RAI which is
the official organization that tries to
not impose but to put all the rules
about the Spanish we can see a heat map
of populations Mexico of course is the
largest country speaking English sorry
Spanish and us is actually the second
country speaking in Spanish with more
than 50 million so I split them by by
state so there are states with more
speakers than even any Central America
country so it's interesting that you
have also a large population of Spanish
speakers in countries like Australia or
Japan so with more than 100,000 speakers
so actually releasing WolframAlpha in
Spanish will let us reach millions of
people
of course the main block of speakers is
in America America continent has most of
the speakers then Europe and then the
rest of the world so and now we can see
some examples so this is going to be the
main entry point so we already have here
a working web and we should be able to
ask anything but not anything but we are
in Paris of working on it and of course
we have translated the the solutions
step the step by step solutions so we
can show all these steps and how to do
them in Spanish so we have a lot of
domains or a translated of course most
of math domains are already in place we
still need let's say quality review of
course this is one case of the for
example that we needed to actually do
something for having an agreement
between the world and the ordinance for
example in Spanish so it wouldn't be the
same if this world were a family meaning
world because you will need to say that
Sarah instead of tercer so now in all
the ordinal places we have added what's
the gender of the next word and
something else is that the we needed to
add that for each language because the
gender in each language may be different
so the gender of a word in Spanish is
different at the gender of the same
Gordon German or in French or in well in
French Brown is going to be similar one
but in German or in other language yeah
so that's part of all this challenge we
needed to figure out how to solve here
is also an example where I had a mixing
of commas and points and it's filled out
both should be commas or decimal
separator we have noticed translated the
assumptions by the way sorry
still on progress but the idea is that
you can also choose oh that comma was
not for a decimal separator but for a
least separator so that should be able
to to interpret that way
so this should be formatting I guess yes
because I'm loading with my user it
sings I know so it's formatting with the
time for for the time song in Peru so
for example for for what day is today
we can also interpret this in different
ways if I want to know that full date or
only there which day of the week is it
is the same manner so all this is part
of the
and of course calculus is one of the
main points we we have to solve and we
have also already done the effort of
when we have oh let's show this case of
the solving two equations so it figures
out correctly that it is to equation
that I want to solve for now we don't
have any assumption but maybe we will
need that of course that in the result
that looks nice because we have a
different gray form to show the and so
you can actually see the difference the
solution works this is a step by step
solution so we can have all these nicely
there of course I want to before we
finish they have one minute I think we
have already translated all these all
the math examples still we need to
translate the head so in the example
places we can browse all the examples
how they are working let's take one you
know by Laurie propios for example eigen
values and in this case for example I
think yes he did correctly this 4 comma
1 was interpreted correctly as a part of
the matrix because it didn't make sense
to interpret that as a one value one
decimal value in this case because you
already had a list of two values a
second part so everything should be a
matrix so it in the press correctly that
in this case the coma is a least
separator and well it's working fine
they step-by-step etcetera so well I
think I'm over at the time so if you
have any other quick question yes yes we
have already translated 4500 units for a
Spanish and it's being a long effort and
also in another language is even more
problematic for example in Russian we
needed to add more fields to all the
plurals which is actually the genitive
case and for for Russian for for
expressing the figures but yes that's
been done yes yes also so you can ask
for five matters and it should show the
the actual five metros and sixteen pas
pulgadas so yes we've been doing that
yep
any other question before we finish yes
yes common functions like say no and
those are translated for display but of
course we understand both the English
and the Spanish for yes well I think we
are done thank you very much for for
your attention
you